maurice must continue under the fingers
raise your righteous
the steel and the time taken have brought
with you their weakness and not to
despair yours we must fion our
prisoners and novara
we do not pray for the victims of
terrorism who instrumentalize including the
old  bones but the earth so that
speedwells years they will arrive and
many lives feel excluded
consumer society that the
nomadic spirit is spreading in abundance on
our dream the essay
on these regions
[Music]
these maps and gentlemen  please
step back it's going to move
[Music]
we put on our paths
it's her thighs that we
[Music]
but I'm going to listen we're not
stopped moving it please the
processors go
[Music]
so
the bike
[Music]
kal penn station I knew meet his
mother
[Music]
otherwise he advanced by some magistrates
in three orange sets called him to judge
khaled member in the shadows  in israel  they
must be a sign a great buffon the
profession and even sees had the berries that
transfer by hand on the way to the
point this figure comes from jesus who
accompanies 10 km from the first
these will be they on the branch ea
sola the lordship  of his father he
[Music]
and saw vs will not play the same
the operation is intended for as many
heifers year this meeting is also
in the face of traction and three same
sweats it does not bother her of this
amenity these two rounds estimating her
thoroughbred  of the circumference of 300 runners are
106 that I get angry rights and their
duties of the angel signs to those
appearing on track 0.1 but unanimously
the law it is a contraction she is the
first church
the second sentinel and sees the icy
[Music]
gold he
he ran 3 1
and the those who are in pain and
to initiate everything here for a long time and
win the comfort mr of the sums
allocated smooth communication and for the
news that so often a valley of
tears  s and wish to keep in condition
[Music]
we feel you went
to
[Music]
[Applause]
ahah
[Music]
and
be
[Music]
oh
the waters
[Music]
oh
the waters
m
I put it
then
non
alé lô
av
[Music]
to
go
[Music]
fifth station simon of cyrène est de
jesus carried his cross
good so it's the other but neither his
[Music]
he requires to carry his cross simon
of cyrene the father of alexander and moreover
who passed by
returning from the fields
the rank of them occurs
cement who returns from his work and
jesus exhausted that there is no longer the strength
to carry his cross when we  are
good friends of the test via an angel the
consolation the sonars call this man
who passes for link necks and to carry the
cross of the man cedh condemned it
becomes the iron of jesus simon does
not measure the grace of these meetings of the  is there
and he does not know it but he does not suspect
that this being if figures and that
there is no pl  us that themselves and the alpha and
the omega the first and the last he
who is who was and who comes christ
is beautiful of the only beauty that
simply because they cross the
sleeve if we bear our pain with
the lord our weight  of each day
enables us to shine with the very
compassion of god who has made
everything in this world
beautiful the scandal of suffering can then become a mystery of birth [Music] to christ who gave simon of cyrene
the dignity of  wear cold
2 welcome us kindergarten is filled
with compassion the greatness of man
the strength of a nation and its ability to
weave fraternal bonds
across differences community or religion
in the living memory of its roots do
not entrust our  country in its diversity
passionate about the root of the
Christian faith so that it finds a
happy unity in the divisions that
cross
may we live together what
was at the pediment of our buildings
audiences fraternity founded on the awareness
of a common heritage and faith in the
inalienable dignity of man created in
the image of god
[Music]
among us without victory
you are
oo
one feels
[Music]
living
fake
vitois
tuque
at the word his
[Music]
6th at the veronica stations and follows the
face of Jesus
our brave and other countries who are they
and to abandon men familiar with
suffering and before whom we veil
our faces
in symbolic agreement
and here
it can pay for the nic
succeeded in approaching jesus to
study his face bertry and simply
it is a gesture of great gentleness in the
midst of the violence of the path to see
the child woman against the man using
her  is often also the one who
accompanies the man in his death
on seeing him review dreads a
difficult image remains tiny and jesus in his
face this woman face of
painful love pushed to the
extreme seeing him verdu and the first  icon where
we too can be  sucked the face
of the suffering under a great lack of
tenderness every act of love g in the
heart of the one he opposes the holy
face hard and lace by the infamous in the
country however simple it is
we are gradually becoming the face
the church for the world and we
reflect
cole - avi the glory of the lord
her eyes
[Music]
you she is this is the icon of her
face to saint veronica make our
compassion wash away swatch
is presently  the relay of in the
mist
we should especially for the
Christians who in the world are
persecuted for the same way as the
virgin bosom of the embers under her
veil of tenderness that their party awakens
our sleeping west who lives as if
god does not exist  and viscous
to forget more and more the dignity
of prud'hommes in second
[Music]
you my roof flexible and always open
m
during July
him
days
[Music]
be
sir
he must
weare
happening
I
7th stat  ion jesus trombe a second
way we will give back to the crises of
our country nor
his  it was possible his peers passable
far from him
[Music]
jesus falls a second time and gets up
we have to meditate on this he often falls and gets up
again when we fall on the
weight of our faults
we stay on our heads out of despair or
laziness undermined  by the feeling of being
incapable of conversion but nothing is
impossible for god and love 30 in
science getting up for the second
time
jesus well getting us up
again usually from slavery and the
monotony of sin  ask the Lord for
the grace of deliverance for those of
our brothers who are slaves to
pornography which constantly awaits
the envy of the drug of alcohol and
all forms of addiction let us pray that
they grant us  get up
all  days of our falls
so great and illuminates and be it
[Music]
same source of human freedom
relief in the unceasing experience
of god's mercy doctors are
not what ever falls to me means they
always have this  big loot same meaning
are hidden in the wounds of christ
who never tires
of
talking  cross each day and to get
up with perseverance from a daily juice
you who washed the feet of forfeit target
to return to give them again grace 1
and find us the grace of the sacrament
of reconciliation which frees us and
we sandy  vee 3 who aim reigns
for centuries
[Music]
c
life in front of paris
[Music]
except one
ah good
[Music]
oh
then
[Music]
it's good
I often have for pharmacies
he does not  vibrate assure bob  and and to the children
I'm going back to mauricie
it happened
[Music]
and the subject
essay
I accuse
[Music]
m
the 6-12s
and the past the
logical company of the
world
m
[Music]
large number
l  apology
understands who contributes to his soul they
come to live together glassmakers
multiplied Thursday
worse and worse resort to it
at the front what transpires has all had
time to take place
we are clearly running in
order to the destiny of the works
the ease this program
to  taken whatever evolves in the
world will be able to decide france this very
wrong of salvation it is that our generation
that the time that your life you know
tells me vendée its hope the faith which
makes its credo valiant morning jean not
rewrite history in  waiting for his
fruits from his 3d view the former evolved centuries
of centuries
issouf koné
[Music]
oh
e
the
see me again
yes
playing high
you
even two
far
oh
we are badly done
you know how much
[Music]
oh
au  turn
such a c  limat
that make you laugh but well the stations
jesus falls for the third time
we are going that they did not owe his
[Music]
the disenchantment around what was struggling under
the weight of the burden and I would
relieve you loaded you with my day and
put you to  my school because i am 12
and a bhl of heart and you find
rest for your souls jesus falls a
third time to overcome
the hardness of our heart
the history of salvation is a succession
of falls and offended lord we
see it  in the first covenant in
the murmurings of the people in the desert in
the worship of the golden calf in
the hypocrisy of the Pharisees and the pride
of the leaders of the people we see it
in the versatility of the apostles have the
triple denial of stone we see it
finally saw with shame in all the history
of the church the
one who makes the truth comes to
light the truth is a
painful light a double-edged sword
so that we a people of poor and
sinners slow to c  understand not
conversion ask the grace that this
third fall of the lord
obtain us to become ever more worthy
of the health that god gives to his church
by his word and the sacraments
lord we pray to you especially for
the holiness of the priests and their fidelity
to the  'call received to kill we give you
thanks for the immense people waste of the
good servants
we invite to the six weeks what
blows and what has no confidence who
their honor
with a nerve to beg to grant a
soil izon objectives is there  the only one
who diverts for the benefit of evil the unique
parity
eva joly has been made in all truth and
light with the church
a promising verification in the midst of the
world of the books of the briefs of all was
reborn from the abuse of power of their
mission  of the servile commission before
express you came to observe not to
be served
akon remains one the one of service and
poor d gospel according to m
as it
does it
[Music]
his vi  e is one
one bad
[Music]
he is in his life round for the 10
of their income to serve
[Music]
[Applause]
lee
about together and if you the tenth
station jesus was  wet and
clothes have not trained since
[Music]
he will be of age except his clothes by
drawing lots
which is good for everyone the body
of the lord and I will act as a hostage to see him
the holy supper
and now yes in the eyes of  all in
his dick and painful this wounded body
bears on the suffering of the world and to
marc of the sin which was six months
of aborting the original man we
are created in the image of god did not free us
the resemblance by moving them away
from the highest serrières and I live from
their it was without removing the brilliance without
appearance for us it is the body
seems in crisis
has just shown how much evil or
ridiculous but it is in order to restore
their image
this corner retreat is  the very one that will
result in  death the excessive worry
that seems to him the vanity mandel and
the pride of the ark is center as
many nazi camp
two clichés our pleasure
the skier reveals who we are here
[Music]
there tell you who saves the world
isn't it  not the aesthetic appearance
don't hesitate but the beauty christ which
passes through the quack of death which
is recurrent in the darkness and which
the rennais did not stop at all
the humility vehicles and making the
tributes of haddock cairo
she was so beautiful lord our
cathedral and her highest vote
and be the skulls the presence a bhl is
veiled in the guise of a small
piece of bread we a look
sure enough to be able to essential us to
detach ourselves from  what attracts our
gaze to defend ourselves from all that
dedicate themselves that fly high level
to turn us towards the light of
things that are not seen of trusting
the immense people of what we put
on board because of their handicap
or  their weakness
the children who are prevented from nerves
the elderly the sick come to us to
discern the presence through and more
wounded and suffering of our brothers and
gives us the inner look the faith
that puts everything back
[Music] [Music]
]
[Music]
auj
11th station jesus is nailed to the cross
it's long
[Music]
it was the third hour when he
crucified the inscription which indicated
the reason for the condemnation was
worded the king of the  Jews is carried out and
one crucified two vying for it on the
right the other on the left
we are witnessing nice is of extreme
violence this violence which rises so often from the
heart of the work
it arouses in us a complicity or
an unhealthy curiosity wounded by  our
sins we are to be drawn easily
by what is impure and by what is
violent but a reality has never
risen from the heart of man the
one who is crucified and and god the
creator of heaven and earth
the king
[Music
] king
wade century
i
c
relaxed what good is it
centuries
m
2 man invented the cross as a
torment but he did not imagine that his
lord could die on the cross such
is the truth of our faith
radically  foreign to any
human thought of god when man thinks of
god imagines an all powerful in
the image of the idols of the money of
power
but we proclaim tram and six pillars
scandal for the jews
pauli for the valiant for what
god calls this messiah and power of
god and wisdom of god because what is
madness of god is wiser than
men and what is weakness of god
is stronger than men here the
lord reveals himself in total
helplessness but in the  all power
of love mr forgive them they do
n't know what they are doing with seven
words of christ employment comes the
reversal of violence in
god's forgiveness and all hope that we
had done this
unica hail you oprah unique
hope  rancid we want to say to him with the
great
prayer christ is the only name that can
save us
to christ raised from the earth draw all men to you
after we recognize in the
cross the unique site of our intention
is that we live
with you grant  to the Christian people who
these rains come along this very
case to be renewed indefinitely in
the coldness the door to hope must
cook for axle
[Music
] honey
[Music]
not
and
he
good
[Music]
[Music]
no
there
[Music]
no
the old station that's
why
[Music]
no
when he had the 6th the darkness trusts
on the whole earth until
half an hour
and at the 9th
his eyes that the mom
[Music]
that there picks up with dany
what he wants
here he had been
[Music]
for with a beautiful
bouncing smile let  that we see if
and irony
oh jesus
a veil of owed
ehud barak
seeing that he had thus expired
this man
the centurion is a little shaken by these
mountains and which were not committed
jesus did not return
he said to monday two
dany today you will be with me
in maradi
led to the  hospital
2 following the death of the lord
this was the son of god
ask for grace
look at russia with voice
fillon him from where our faithful and the souls
of purgatory
I am
he places his spirit in the hands of the
father and announces the tone  from the holy spirit
to pentecost
it is not a
spirit first received
but an obvious risk
love wisdom
price in colors of our hand
the mysterious moment that will complete the
course of our earthly life so that
we can surrender our spirit
in the hands of father
adam morris emotions
that no one at the sacred moment
else may the lord in an
instant you look upon with mercy
as he did to the whodunnit
[Music]
shining
hairstyle
in my last breath
[M  usique]
with you
and standing
we give up
a
the centuries of the centuries
but
it's
I advance in a
and
I
[Music]
attention
I
[Music]
oh
I
as an army
[Music]
even behind
the tournament
[Music]
oh
contact
[Music]
attention I knew
came down from the cross ends
etc
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
of the faith of Jesus what the abers and
the sister of his  mother marry the good man
with faces and mary of magdala jesus
our beliefs ahmed and standing
near her the disciple who loved ita his
mother poissy woman in the empires
difficult to a voice if the sea 5 p.m.
the municipal harmony welcomed  the sky
I
composed live nobody there is
nobody
you
el fassi
but who do not stop living and the civilians
of the flame
but very quickly analyzed
this
but possible
yesterday justin from our lady of paris so
beautiful who had six  wounded
grant us the grace to come to
you we c  let us trust all those who
have two
to deliver our cathedral from the
flames those who took in silence
those who acted with courage the
firefighters the police
the actors of the political life of our
holy virgin nation we give you thanks
for the unity the
generosity that  you have paid
vestri in these hours
of hope show yourselves our bread and
our queen and protect us in all
our fights
ask you for it by this list beloved
reigns there for centuries of centuries
[Music]
fr
and we sell them
fake
[  Music]
oh
because guys
[Music]
that
to
[Music]
we
alipour
[Music]
already the evening had come and how it was
the repair
we will see
[Music]
altarpiece of the consensus which was also waiting for
the kingdom on
Sunday to prove to me
the body of jesus
he has already died
he sent the body
brightening task and not
the shooting
oh
we
the family
[Music]
according to m
hello
[  M  usique]
[Music]
here is the time of the south
the clans of legs
today
taking it
we will go back the other way after
attention
lord give us lagrasse to
enter hope through the door of dassin
jitrois and  scrutinize the end of the
night meditating on the promise if the pr
combe is in truce he remains alone but
under their blows
oh
[Music]
he is
and
oh
no
andwe
[Music]
e
no
[Music]  ]
and you
[Music]
oh
let's go
to
[Music]
oh
to the sound
[Music]
the lord
sells with you
through the painful and immaculate heart of
the virgin mary our lady of
paris god bless you bank that st
[Music]
[  Music]
m
[Music]
sun in the face of the three over there
the data when
it's fine
and
gm
[Music]
info
the already
it's wrong
[Music]
but not
but good
everything
[Music]
ah good
m
[Music]
en
non
[Music]
d
eleven years
[Music]
[Music
] something to
find  happened
understand that it could us
[Music]
in saint sulpice I think no that do
n't know I don't know I really like to hear
why
[Music]
we're going to be blocked
please  not that's how it is for the
moment for the undetermined press the
procession left doubled there the
disappearance version the Stations of the Cross
had hitherto
[Music]
ok
yes